the Joe Rogan experience yeah I think
this is the most polarized time I can
remember as a 51 year old man looking
back at you know my history of paying
attention to social issues and the way
we communicate with each other and just
the partisan attitudes that people seem
to have I don't I don't I mean I think
it's probably because of Trump that's a
giant part of it but it's also just a
sign of the times of social media I
think it's in part engineered by the
algorithms of Facebook and Twitter and
and all these other social media
companies utilize and it's also been
engineered by bath bad-faith
participants and people that are
actually manipulating it I don't know if
you've paid any attention to Sam Harris
had a fantastic podcast with and we had
one with her as well Renee Durr esta
when they'd arrest analyzed all of the
various accounts that the IRA had
created with the internet research
agency that was responsible for all of
these fake accounts that people thought
were black lives matter accounts or
pro-southern secession accounts or all
these different accounts that were very
polarizing and are arguing with other
people that these were just Russians
that were working for this organization
that was specifically trying to start
chaos they were specifically trying to
start arguments and when when you you
see that and then I mean that's a factor
that's a giant factor that kind of [ __ ]
is a factor and that that is sort of
become part of the sport of social media
has been arguing absolutely I don't do
it I don't engage but I do go on
Facebook sometimes and someone makes an
abortion post and I just watch the chaos
like oh my god yeah it's in or anything
having anything to do with Trump or
anything having anything to do with the
Second Amendment or anything that has
anything to do with the wall or
immigration so I don't know that people
are actually in larger disagreements
right they were previously I think that
yes Trump has coarsened the language and
the way in which it's now acceptable to
talk about a lot of these things that's
number one
I think the social media algorithms like
you're pointing out reward the most
extreme and polarizing comments and
reactions in a never-ending feedback
loop where the most polarizing initial
tweet generates a more responses than
less polarizing tweets and then the sub
responses that are most polarizing and
an aggressive do the exact same thing
and it's never-ending feedback loop I
think it's all those things but I don't
know that people are having bigger
disagreements than in times past I just
think that they're public in a different
way well there's more disagreements
because people have more opportunity to
disagree so they're more opportunity to
engage and particularly talking about
people that are addicted to their phones
and it's coming from a guy uses [ __ ]
phone four hours a day right I'd like to
think that one hour that is productive
but I know that three hours of is me
staring at butts on Instagram look at
muscle cars and watch more video and
then how much are you on like a computer
I don't know I didn't I don't have that
that data right but it's not as much and
the good thing about it is most my
[ __ ] I'm doing on the phone
most of my computer work unless I'm
laying in bed I just watch
embarrassingly enough i watch youtube
videos on pool that's what i watch me i
go to bed yeah that's interesting why i
play pool yeah so i watch like
professional pool matches before i go to
bed because it's not harming yeah it's
relaxing and I analyze positions that's
interesting I do the same thing with
chess oh that's what I there's like
chess streamers it's similar
yeah that's Q could kick back and sort
of it's you're engaged but it's nothing
crazy and it's also kind of stimulating
in an intellectual way right yeah and
it's different than politics yes yes
like on weekends when people you know
like my mom will you know I want to talk
to me about politics oh and I'm just
like I did this all week mom yeah mom
watch your show she does and she watches
other shows and my family's super
political so really I so on the weekends
if it's Saturday I'm right in the middle
of my break period because they
left-wing oh yeah thank God yeah of
question could you arise some mean dad
calling you up what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you David I might have had to defu
ah Dee foo mmm
oh yeah anyway anyway indeed I think
that there's more opportunity as or
saying yeah listen to disagree with
people more opportunity to argue and in
those more opportunities you're seeing
more conflict and I think more
polarization and I think again the
social media algorithms and all the
other nonsense that gets I think there's
I really do believe that the the feeling
that I get but it also might be because
a big part of my job is being on the
internet so maybe I'm more engaged with
it our books excuse it a little bit yeah
but I think so in practice it Matt let's
imagine that the disagreements are equal
to what they've always been
but there's more opportunities to
disagree and the algorithm favors more
escalated disagreement than rational
conversation the effect is that you
might meet someone with whom you have
80% in common in terms of your political
views mm-hm
but the circumstances in which you
engage with that person are going to be
on the 20 percent that you don't so it
makes it seem as though you just have
very little common ground with anybody
right because the 80 percent agreement
becomes background and the social media
platforms the debates happening on
YouTube
elsewhere are focused only on like the
most divisive fraction of one's entire
political views and that's I think what
the problem is hmm but it makes sense
because most people agree that I don't
know
gas stations I mean just to pick
something innocuous most people agree
that it's good to have a regulatory
system that makes sure that when you
think you've pumped five gallons of gas
you've gotten five gallons of gas yes
it's so uncontroversial that nobody's
going to talk about it like it makes
sense that the focus is going to be on
the disagreements where it's damaging is
then when you meet people in real life
and it's hard to relate or even be in
the same room because only those
differences are sort of like played up
or right yes yes yes yeah yeah that that
conflict gets highlighted you have
conflict bias yeah yeah I I don't know
where I see this going that's one of the
more interesting things about
particularly with social media and like
things when you come to this crowd
situation I don't know where this is
going because I didn't know this was
ever going to be a thing I had never
really considered that there was going
to be some digital town square that
we're all going to be enjoying whether
it's Twitter or YouTube or whatever it
is that might even need regular yeah
that might even need regulation